since the dawn of time there have been  vampires  and then there's me waiting to pounce  yep  hey guys stream team 29th of april  stream team tv like and subscribe  [Music]  i got a call from director's people he  personally requested the stream team to  come out to his retreat new mexico  the chat about a huge ambassador deal  who's this guy  you got no idea how much trouble you're  in do you you've been warned  what if these people aren't just greedy  they're evil  it's gonna be fine okay  welcome everyone queen of online  shopping  king of youtube  an online social goddess  i wouldn't say goddess  why are people saying that all the time  i just got a ping from downstairs  they're ready for david this is where i  leave you  where's david hello  [Music]  jesus  jack come with me now before it's too  late  the games are over honey  welcome to the rest of your life  are you ready  bring it vamp  this isn't what we signed up for  that's the truth baby  [Music]  that's cool  you